spero con questo video di riuscire a
farvi capire perché ho preso questa
decisione anche se il più delle volte
molto probabilmente non ci capite una
mazza
ciao a tutti oggi vorrei parlarvi di una
cosa con particolarmente a cuore
ora non so se se lo sapete ma la maggior
parte delle persone che voi seguite su
youtube su facebook o instagram alle
spalle un'agenzia che li aiuta a gestire
il proprio lavoro e per carità per
chiunque volesse iniziare un percorso
lavorativo su internet avere un'agenzia
è importantissimo ma non fondamentale
ecco perché al ritorno delle vacanze ho
preso una decisione e ho pensato di fare
un salto indietro nel tempo ai miei
primi anni su youtube e tornare a
gestire il mio canale da solo quando vi
qualcosa di nuovo e un pochino come
ritrovarsi bambini quando ogni
esperienza era come un pacco da scartare
una tela bianca che aspettava solamente
lì per essere dipinta che sia stato il
primo morso un pezzetto di cioccolato il
primo bacio la prima volta contributo
naxoo una telecamera
la prima cosa che ho fatto è stata
sempre seguire l'istinto così come viene
senza preoccupazioni le domande problemi
una paura di sbagliare anche perchè
all'inizio non esistono strade giuste o
sbagliate che siano
il sopra si confonde col sotto la destra
con la sinistra è l'ultima cosa di cui
ti preoccupi rabuffo anche la più
piccola delle cose sembra creata
soltanto per te il mare sulla pelle
quando quando cammini sul bagnasciuga
l'odore dell'erba mentre correre dietro
al pallone
la meraviglia delle stelle cadenti al
modo in cui tagliano il cielo giocando a
nascondino tra di loro
e quel momento cambia tutto perché
quando un fuoco brucia
bisogna trovare sempre un modo per
spegnerlo così muta il modo in cui vieni
parli con
ogni giorno qualcuno che insegna
qualcosa di nuovo come comportarti
cosa dire
cosa tacere ma soprattutto cosa fare
come farlo
le regole dopo regolano le parole che
dici non sono neanche più le tue ma ma
sono quelle dei libri che letto dei film
che visto le canzoni che fischietti
sotto la doccia sono i cinque che
abbassano la tv
se poi a mare devi imparare a correre
lontano
se vuoi ballare dimissioni reati per
disegnare bisogno di una matita
legge una gomma per cancellare su errori
perché di errori ne farai così giorno
dopo giorno indossino strato di colore
nuovo nella speranza di coprire dei tuoi
errori cerchi di avvicinarsi sempre di
più alle aspettative che le persone
nutro nei tuoi riguardi e e finisce per
assomigliare sempre di meno a te stesso
e allora va bene così hanno ragione loro
e pur di dimostrare a me stesso che si è
ancora libero visto che non riesce a
fare la cosa giusta inizia a fare quella
sbagliata
i racconti di essere felice anche quando
ha smesso di sorridere è innamorato
interessa più
perché in fondo sotto sotto non avrei
mai avuto bisogno a volte quando non sai
che direzione sta andando ti senti noi
non ti con cieco
l'unico modo per fare un passo avanti
è quello di farlo
[Musica]
nessuno allora che ti rendi conto che la
tela per essere bella non è mai servito
che fosse perfetta ma per forza si
tragici dovevamo essere non bastava di
che mi ero messo in proprio senza fare
quanta propri cazzo ma nov